Why are Dalmatians the Traditional Dog of
Choice at Firestations?
One of the most effective fire-fighting tools
in the middle of the 18th century was the
steam pumper- a machine that consisted of
a boiler which was able to use steam to force
water out of hoses and onto a fire.
The fire brigade’s horse-drawn carriages
would be loaded up with the machine, the horses
would be hitched up, and the vehicle would
tear off down the road.
When fire fighters were racing off to fight
the flames, they didn’t have time for the
horses to spook nor to slow down for all the
pedestrians using the road, which is where
the Dalmatians came in.
Besides being known for forming strong bonds
with horses, in the early 1700s, it was observed
that Dalmatians were perfectly suited for
travelling long distances.
As stated by the Dalmatian Club of America,
the English felt that Dalmatians had the “strength,
vitality, fortitude and size to keep running
along under the carriage for hundreds of miles.”
When the travellers rested for the night,
the dogs were also useful for standing guard
over the horses and the people’s belongings.
English aristocrats soon picked up on the
practice of having Dalmatians follow their
carriages and the dogs even became something
of a symbol of social status- the more Dalmatians
that ran alongside your carriage, the wealthier
you must be.
Back to Dalmatians and the horse-drawn fire
carriages- because of the dogs’ strong work
ethic and stamina, they typically didn’t
have any trouble keeping up with the carriages
even when they were flying down the roads
at high speeds.
The Dalmatian would scare away anything that
might spook the horses, and also just as importantly
served as the first “siren.”
Its bark would alert pedestrians on the road
that the fire brigade was on its way, and
to move off the street.
The horses were also a bit leery of being
so close to burning buildings when it came
time to stop.
(Can you blame them?)
While the firemen unloaded their equipment
and rushed off to put the fire out, their
trusty Dalmatians would stay with the cart,
keeping the horses calm and guarding the firemen’s
belongings.
Not only that, but once they were back at
the fire house, the Dalmatian were often trained
to sniff out and kill rats and other vermin—kind
of like having a barking cat that was far
less lazy than a meowing mouse-catcher.
When the much more efficient motorized fire
trucks were created, there were no longer
horses for Dalmatians to keep company and
no need for them to run ahead of the trucks
to alert people that the fire brigade was
coming—there were sirens for that now.
Their usefulness spent, Dalmatians might have
vanished from fire stations altogether.
Instead, they turned into fire station mascots,
particularly popular when firefighters go
around teaching kids about fire safety.
Of course, at this point any dog could be
used, and sometimes that’s the case, but
given the long standing tradition of using
Dalmatians, it seems likely they will remain
the dog of choice at many fire stations for
the foreseeable future.
A common myth is that Dalmatians are kept
in fire houses because unlike other breeds,
the loud sound of the siren won’t hurt their
ears.
While it is true that Dalmatians are predisposed
to deafness (only about 70% have normal hearing),
they were originally around to primarily function
as a siren, as stated, so their hearing wasn’t
really
a factor.